there are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products to test
for ourselves i'm a big fan of the made
by mitchell blushes i tried a purple
blush from them before and i loved it
and they just came out with a lavender
shade so i had to try it applying it on
top of my makeup was a mistake because
it's a pastel it was basically like i
applied a white blush over my bronzer
plus it actually made my foundation
patchy which is an issue that i've never
had with this formula i think i might
have just over blended trying it out on
bare skin wasn't any better it just
leaves this very gray looking cast i
looked like the corpse bride i think i'm
better off using this as an eyeliner and
eye shadow base clinique has finally
come out with a lip gloss version of its
iconic black honey lipstick this color
is definitely identical to the lipstick
version just glossy here's what they
look like side by side i liked it a
little more once i dab some off this
color is just really flattering i have
to say though this gloss formula is not
my favorite i think they were going for
a cushiony feel but it's just kind of
sticky and thick looks great but it
doesn't feel so great elf released this
halo glow liquid filter and the world
stopped could this actually be a dupe
for the charlotte tilbury flawless
filter let's see on this side of my face
i applied flawless filter it's gorgeous
it's glowy it's perfect now on this side
i applied the elf halo glow look at them
side by side they are almost identical i
would say that the elf one has a hint
more coverage but it still gives that
same your skin but better effect and the
charlotte tilbury one is slightly more
glowy slightly i say save yourself the
extra 30 bucks and get the elf one side
note look at the size of the stove foot
it's huge you guys know i adore rare
beauty i was so excited when they
dropped these kind words matte lipsticks
and lip liners i had to get the color
gifted because selena said that that was
her favorite the lip liner is super
smooth even though it's matte it doesn't
drag or pull on the lips plus it's a
twist up which i love the lipstick is so
creamy and pigmented you could probably
put this on in one swipe it's definitely
one of the most comfortable matte
lipsticks i've ever tried scrandy beauty
is a brand i found on tick tock i kept
seeing videos of its spicy sauce lip
plumper and i really wanted to test it
out since i haven't had much look with
lip lumpers i applied it to half my lips
so we could see if it actually does
anything so you apply it slightly above
your lip line and it starts to feel a
little spicy then it starts to feel
tingly and spicy and then at the three
minute mark you also start to feel a
warming sensation i love lip plumpers so
i don't mind the roller coaster this
takes you on it feels kind of good to me
i definitely noticed plumping especially
with my top lip i really like this lip
plumper and i also like that it's clear
so you can wear it on top of anything
[Music]
you